daniel jeremiah joins us in studio now
at move the sticks we're going to sit
down with him boys you want to come over
law chris you want to be a part of this
substituting for you oh yeah yeah we can
you want to go over here
in the studio you can we're just moving
on the fly let's go hey guys we like to
move around this is a fluid set hey
daniel hi nice to meet you thank you for
coming in i appreciate it
whatever you want come
nice to be here just can i request
brockman though can we put law on the
other side oh yeah okay fine
i'm just saying this is the handle
there's no dig i just look at the
t-shirt it's the handsome couch we have
the same sock collection so what do you
got i went plane i went plane he never
goes playing yeah what are you wearing
what do you mean
yeah they're great
uh
i talked to les need yesterday okay
about austin davis obviously lesney
being the jam of the rams and
we were talking about his preparation i
think a lot of people have been
surprised at how well he's come out and
played but les has had a great point
which is that he's been sitting there
watching for three years what's the
difference in challenge for a
quarterback who's sitting watching
who's still a rookie still going to come
in and take that first snap but versus a
guy like sam bradford before him who
came straight off the bench
well i mean we the you hear the phrase
mental reps a lot and everybody gives
lip service to it oh you know i'm
getting mental reps this week and when
you get your chance to get on the field
you find out who has been taking those
mental reps going through that preparing
every week every day like you're going
to be the guy even though he knew he's
hoping to make the team before the
season starts so i think from that
standpoint of maturity that existed in
him and i scouted him coming out of
southern miss i remember talking to him
at the east west game and i wrote in my
notes um this guy he personality wise
kind of reminds me of drew brees he's
just got that same kind of demeanor to
him i'm not saying he's going to be drew
brees when i asked him at the end of the
interview i said hey favorite player
anybody you model yourself after drew
brees les got a kick out of the fact
that brett favre would go on and say
that he's as he could be as good as
peyton manning or as good as tom brady i
think he was saying that's a lot of
hyperbole but you know that's also less
being
being less but how good is this kid well
he doesn't have that elite arm strength
so he's not going to wow you from that
standpoint but what he does he can
manage the game he can be very efficient
and accurate underneath intermediate
things like that i think it's somebody
you need to have guys around him and
we've seen the development of some of
their younger players kendricks and
titan's done a nice job now he's got a
running back behind him and trey mason
out of auburn they're finally giving him
the ball and doing some things so i
don't think he's one of these players
going to make around him better but i
think you put him in a place where
you've got some stable players i think
you can win with them do you get is
there any issue it
sam bradford they kind of doubled down
on him again this year austin davis is
coming in there he's doing some really
good things
is is he you know any footsteps or her
footsteps being heard well i don't think
if you're the rams you can rely on sam
bradford anymore i mean it's a sad deal
you hate to see him get injured like he
has but you can't go into this offseason
thinking he's going to be your starter
and going to play 16 games he hasn't
really proven he can do that so i
believe austin davis is really
auditioning for next year in the future
right now you talk about mental reps
we've been getting mental raps law and
eye for three plus years
behind rich and we were kind of hoping
fridays rich is out maybe we're ready to
get the mental reps in nope brings in
his wife
so he
that's not like giving me the biggest
compliment you can say
she's tom brady okay we want to go tom
brady you can switch that up
i don't know
like kyle orton was brought high priced
right they gave him a lot of money girl
she's really funny like don't you think
personality work yourself out of this
one
because what i'm saying is what i'm
getting at is by the way we'll be right
back after this i'm going to wrap this
up keep going you just get your foot out
these guys are ej manuel right okay so
now work with me on this so the first
round they went out and found some
high-priced insurance because they
weren't sure ej manuel right was going
to be ready to go
appearance you know production we're not
going kyle orton at all just you know an
expensive insurance policy for these
guys he did a pretty good job working
his way out of that i don't buy it
we're just suffering through that one
i'm not gonna forget that one should we
talk college football because my poor
husband is having an awful time of it
right now with brady hockey
i love brady i think he's just a
terrific guy i have a problem with a
with a head coach this day and age not
wearing a headset and that's solely just
because you know it's 2014. i love him
we love the michigan program but what's
happening there and will he survive the
season well you kind of look at all
these these places where they've had
issues and there's talk of change you
look at must-champ in florida same thing
at michigan you don't identify the right
quarterback and at a place like michigan
where we've seen for years and years
that's where the nfl was popping out all
these quarterbacks it's been a while now
since they've had a guy that you could
really rely on and they have the
resources in the name to go out and
select guys you're not recruiting you're
selecting the players you want and so
the evaluation of the quarterback i
think will be his downfall but are you
really selecting as much anymore i mean
it's so it's changed so much where
quarterbacks are so corded and touted
and unless they have the head coach they
want to play for it's not as easy it's
not like they're resting on the laurels
of the michigan program anymore yeah but
i mean the challenge is you look at
places like east carolina where they're
successful shane carden their
quarterback and i mean all those big
time programs have had a chance to
evaluate quarterbacks like that had a
chance to offer him and bring him in
he's not going to turn down michigan to
go play at east carolina so a lot of
times we get focused on the coaching job
that they're doing and i think it more
comes the line of recruiting and
developing your players jameis winston
had a huge game last week florida state
beat notre dame did he do
did he do anything to kind of help him
in the eyes of nfl draft evaluators i
think he just reminded people about the
on the field stuff we've spent so much
time looking at all of his off-field
issues which there's plenty of time to
sort all that stuff out some of it very
serious obviously but on the football
field he's the most talented passer in
college football and that second half
against notre dame was near flawless he
looked incredible it was fantastic and
the one thing about him that i think is
kind of special it's rare to find a big
armed guy which he is he was a 95 mile
an hour fastball on the baseball diamond
they can throw with anticipation a lot
of times those guys they trust their arm
it's they're gonna wait to see the guy
break and then you see him deliver the
ball he threw with great anticipation in
that one the way the game ended on that
on that pick play which they called
ask brady ask brady quinn about that by
the way yeah which is uh
yeah he did not agree with that he does
not agree with that because it happened
so often and
look we were talking about this the
notre dame receivers could have done a
better job it was very deliberate what
they were doing but
that was a touchdown regardless almost
and
they lost florida state lost on that
play by alignment and all notre dame had
to do if those receivers just either run
through or just turn around square up to
the quarterback it was going to be an
easy touchdown unfortunately you have
the contact and they get the penalty
well we got ole miss this week big game
they're number three taking on 24 lsu
who do you like in that one i like the
upset which is weird lsu
at home yeah playing it's ole miss and
it's like everybody's kind of oh it's
ole miss they're the better football
team lsu at night baton rouge at night
that's not an easy place to go and
they're running the ball a lot better
now uh with their freshman leonard
fournette so i like lsu to pull the
upside have you been to lsu for nike
even have you been to the grove also i
i've been to lsu not for a night game
and i have not been to the grove but lsu
was that i've been at lsu to see them
play georgia and i've been at alabama to
see them play lsu if if anybody has the
money to like do the bucket list of
games that's amazing go to those two
places heisman front runner at this
point you guys by the way since i called
her kyle orton you she's you're not even
gonna let her ask me any more questions
did you just did you notice we're trying
to i didn't notice that yeah no i think
they were trying to see they thought
there was some friction there that
didn't even really exist
now you're
that sounds really bad that being said
that being said
this is the rich eisen show hosted by
susie schuster that being said um let's
talk usc utah another another night game
so what are you expecting there that's
going to be interesting because utah
physically just beat up ucla
got after the quarterback you look at sc
last week we finally saw them get
vertical and that's been my complaint
you've got all these athletes at
receiver and everything's underneath i
want to see them stretch the field and
they did that so
my question is can they do that against
utah who has a very physical front and a
great pass rush i think it's going to be
a real good one don't you feel like
things have settled so much more there
though now with steve sarkeesian back i
mean i i was there when i was hosting
their pregame show he was there lane
kiffin
todd mcnair pete carroll that whole
crowd i mean i just think having him
come back in has been able to settle
that
program a little bit more it's just been
such a crazy couple of years yeah it's
been wild and now you look at them off
sanctions so this year they can take a
full 25 in their recruiting class um so
i think the future is bright for usc
especially you look two or three years
down the road that's why the pressure to
me is on jim moore and ucla because now
sc is coming off sanctions this is kind
of your your time here because sooner or
later a lot of those recruits that have
unable to for usc to take them now they
can in the in the minute or so we have
love with you you had cj mosley on this
week who's
balling out for the ravens on the move
the six podcasts but you also had the
jags gm
caldwell who you're kind of buddies with
and you had a story right before the
draft with a gus bradley well
what happened is i had uh i talked to
dave caldwell before the draft the year
before we've known each other for a long
time and i just said during that year
i'd have the second pick i said i'm
going to give like four or five names of
players you could potentially take
because i'm on the draft coverage and i
want to be able to kind of say what you
liked about him so i called him this
year and i said same thing i'm going to
kind of run through some players so i
asked him about sami watkins and mike
evans and we had talked about three or
four guys and i finally said uh all
right let's get to the quarterbacks i
want to ask you about some of the
quarterbacks he goes hold on i got
another i got another call i gotta run
so yeah i swear fantastic so he would
not
say anything he didn't want to say
anything so they ended up taking blake
bortles which is the big shock so then i
immediately called him the next morning
and i said dude there's nobody on the
other line he's like nah man i didn't
want to lie to you and i'm like what's
worse though lying to me or just like
lying about having somebody on the other
hand because he's still alive but
no pressure for poor blake bortles right
now
he's playing with a bunch of rookies i
mean there are a ton of them he's got
three rookie ride receivers burns
robinson yep and and marquis lee and
they've got two rookie starters on the
offensive line i mean it is a young team
would call did caldwell say anything
about obviously they're impressed with
bortles but uh shoelace from michigan
had a great game last week i mean
because the quarterback in college and
to come out in your first game go over
100 yards i mean
i asked them if it kind of exceeded
their expectations but again we talk
about the preparation that guys that the
guys have and they said he's been so
outstanding and his work ethic that they
really weren't surprised
awesome what do you got brock
i'm just kind of deep in thought you're
really dead
i was going to ask him about like a
rookie quarterbacks in the nfl how you
would grade those guys so far so we can
go in that direction i still really want
to get your heisman thoughts but let's
go rookie quarterbacks in the nfl we'll
go first dak prescott still my favorite
for the heisman quarterback at
mississippi state the young quarterbacks
have all been inconsistent derek carr's
probably been the best one
but teddy bridgewater has had three
tipped interceptions so far in a couple
games so it's going to take him a little
while to adjust uh zach mettenberger by
the way have you showed the picture yeah
no we definitely seen it how have you
this picture is phenomenal how much you
need stones to do that is a rookie
quarterback coming in with the
he's going full ben stiller that makes
me think about what i want to be for
halloween next week but that's what see
everybody was putting all the side by
side that's not creepy
but that's probably another car there's
another whole car there it is there's a
picture look at that look at that that's
phenomenal see i i thought it was kind
of like an ode to steve prefontaine oh
that was the red one yes you know what
it looks like scott spiezio remember old
scotia from the anaheim that's another
that's it
he does right it looks like that's a
good one that's a good one see you just
thought i was kyle orton no no no that's
next level
that's next level
we are not suffering from deficiencies
today coming in we appreciate it next
time you can dig yourself out and call
me another someone else
the rich eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern
on audience